we continue our look at the top 30 story
lines for the 2019 season number nine
something we've been discussing a lot
and i have a feeling we'll continue to
discuss until it happens if it happens
will rob gronkowski come out of
retirement he's been all over the place
on this and who really knows what he's
going to do and he said that himself
recently he told rich eisen he doesn't
know how he's going to feel when the
games get started and that's been my
theory all along he doesn't know what he
doesn't know and he won't know until he
sees his old team in those silver
helmets in those blue and white uniforms
raising that banner a sixth time seeing
guys move forward without him
unless he's got something that is going
to consume his full attention during
football season something that
contractually prevents him from walking
away like a role in a movie or something
like that he'll have that itch and he
may
give in to the temptation to scratch it
and that's something that we'll be
watching week by week by week he has
until week 13 to return to the patriots
and i know he's lost some weight like 18
pounds he says he looks a lot thinner
than that but if he wants to get it back
together he can gain weight quickly i
mean we we all know how easy it is to
gain weight i'm coming off a week of
vacation where uh yeah it's it's time to
it's time to do a little extra cardio
and hit the gym a little hard it's very
easy to put on the pounds and rob
gronkowski can do that if he truly wants
to return to the new england patriots
the other question we need to consider
here that doesn't get mentioned very
often will the patriots want him if he
comes back the fans will want him the
players will want him but think about
bill belichick how he has principles
that are bigger than the individuals who
make up a team will belichick
set what could be a dangerous precedent
by letting a guy just avoid the
off-season program training camp
pre-season the first half of the regular
season barnstorm in and try to win
another super bowl how will belichick
handle that if rob gronkowski decides
that he wants to come back and if
belichick doesn't want him what happens
next does gronkowski end up playing for
someone else i mean these are multiple
steps down the path that we are
exploring but we have to keep this in
mind because it isn't just as simple as
gronk's saying hey i'm back
welcome me back and put me on the field
we learned that 11 years ago when brett
favre tried to come out of retirement
for the first time with the packers
belichick has declined to discuss any of
these potential hypotheticals so we'll
just have to wait and see step one does
gronkowski want to come back step two
will the patriots welcome him back step
three
if they don't things can get very
interesting as the 2019 season unfolds
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports